next up is Chris knowing what you know
today what advice would you have given
yourself when you are first starting
different planning or other ideas ah
that's a great question Chris I think I
would have number one you know I would
have absolutely my idea would have
focused on what is the audience see what
is the custom is what is where do we
find them and then the other great
advice to give myself is surround
yourself with great people and people
who challenge you but people who are on
the same moon mission as you are the
people with the same vision the same
ambition the people who want to kind of
literally fly to the moon and and if you
do that you're probably going to be
shooting success well it might not be
unnecessarily on your first venture but
you'll you'll you'll come across as you
evolve your idea she'd success and in
the context of this of confidence you
know be really happy if you do they'll
learn quick and go to great business
this is a hard one for me because I'm so
happy and grateful for where I am now
that everything that led up to this
moment as shakes who I am and so if I
change something in the past where
they'd still be here it's the internal
battle i had when i get asked this
question but i would probably buy had to
answer would sages believe sooner and
harder I finding believe and going all
in on it has had such a tremendous
impact on my life and on my business and
it's been a newer phenomenon in my life
I mean maybe three four or five years
couple like that if I discovered it
sooner and when it faster it and was
bolder it had more confidence in it that
would probably you know hopefully
further ahead to where I am I'm at now
but at the same time I'm really grateful
for my spot so I think I'd say be a
responsible respect I remember one job
was working really early on in my career
for a big safe company and I resigned to
go to a crazy startup that they've
become a really successful company but I
went back for the weekend it's got my
mom and dad's alive at the fireman
I said to my mum you know I'm gonna go
and do there and she said well who's
this company you leaving you know I
never come to you with but why would you
go and work for a small staff and she
just said here absolutely crazy got
security you got a pension you know
about slide 24 years old and I was just
thinking you know with the benefit of
hindsight I didn't take enough risks in
my early career but just you'll get
loads of people telling you the reasons
why you shouldn't do stuff but I think
it comes back to you in a confidence and
conviction to say if that's what you
believe in they need a chute that they
start and take take more risks jump it's
an interesting question because a lot of
people get that to get not this country
the heat response people are jealous but
if the people are so close to you like
your parents your friends telling you
not to go and do something and for a lot
of people that holds them back as they
really respect and they love their mom
and they want to make them proud and you
know carries family traditions how do
you there what's your advice to people
who want to pursue a path but their
parents are blocking them as the glue
and the other thing of the tunnel oh my
buddy to us crazy for doing it because I
said you know I'm going to start up or
probably with 60 70 80 hours a week and
they said well we won't see any more you
want to be able to come down the pub for
drinks and stuff said well you know I
still come in maybe but i'll be here at
ten o'clock and Eve instead of
statistics on out of it so will it will
find a way to keep those relationships
intact so I think the key thing is and
announcer account is questionable the
best piece of art I have at that age of
24 because I went and did a lot
everybody thinks I'm crazy go and enjoy
the startup and this guy worked with a
new sort of a mentor he said to me
Stephen what what's the worst case that
map the worst case that can happen in a
year is the startup fold or they fire
you and you know what you could knock on
the door of the company you've left and
they'd welcome you back with open arms
and actually you would have gained even
more experience and great life
experience from feeling without failure
and
that you would have been a much much
better entrepreneur yourself so you know
when you look at it rationally and it
sort of divorce yourself from the moment
and then you say well what could really
go wrong here if it didn't work out you
can always go back to where you were I
think where you have to deal with it
seven is you have to be true to yourself
and it kind of comes back to the essence
of where you get your confidence no one
here is living someone else's life un it
you know and this is you know it's not
that profound but we only get one shot
get out of rehearsal and you've got to
make the boat most of the only thing
that just flies past is is time and when
you've got the energy and you're young
and you can work flat-out need like I've
responsibilities it's a fantastic time
to really pursue your passion and really
follow your dreams so I think the folks
who are listening today I mean it's just
a it would be a time if you go home to
your mom did dad even friends and they
say kind of the naysayers don't do it if
you really believe in it then you know
absolutely have the conviction to go and
do it you've got to live your own life